[Music]
a uh uh cambodian lady cambodian a
cambodian lady cambodian marries a cow
after kissed her and followed her
upstairs into her house
how can a cow get upstairs i heard that
happening it's a one floor house you
heard it it is
what they say
when they remain upstairs they mean one
ledge
there's a mystery
it's not sea level the house isn't seen
because i'm like that's just gonna be
right if it's cambodia that foundation
is definitely not leveled you know
fact i heard a story about a cow going
upstairs and once you get it up it's
hard to get out that's what i've heard
i've heard in other stories like you
hear much a lot of stories that are very
useful my friend yeah and i'm just
saying like you know this happens cows
get upstairs it's like an actual problem
they got married
they did get married thanks for bringing
it back to some normal [ __ ] that's a
sign though you gotta marry that cow it
might be cultural i'm gonna ask my
cambodian friend that can't be observed
are you guys married cows they get
divorced is the cow required to give 50
of its milk to her
all the time no good deal
like who makes more money oh that means
she's lesbian unless oh unless cows are
female right oh that's sad yeah so she's
lesbian the campbell's not a bull is it
a female because it's not a bowl right
it's a cow oh these are really profound
questions let me get to the article
this ladies and gentlemen that's what it
is kim
heng she's 74 years old okay she lives
in the northeast crazy province of
cambodia it's not too old to be a
lesbian technically no the lesbians are
usually cut off it's like really close
to them so you know in that part of the
world it's like
people will just come out whenever
because they've got to live their life
yeah at that point you got nothing to
lose when you're 70. you got nothing to
lose
yeah
she uh married it because it kissed her
followed her upstairs as well as had the
same character traits as her dead spouse
she [ __ ] had a kiss from a cow she's
like oh i haven't had any action in so
long bro so she believes it's
reincarnating you think do you think
that the cow kisses like her dead spouse
so her her spouse is actually more
cow-like than the cow is more like human
that's the key that's cute little
kiss-wise what if what if her dead
spouse just licked her face when they
kissed
and now this is what i'm thinking and
just when they went to go like when they
made love he literally would just grab
her face and just lick it yeah instead
of just kissing her and he was also
really good at going upstairs only yeah
that was it
what if he's still upstairs with the cow
if he's not dead he just hasn't come
downstairs
she's all is this cow you i think we
figured it out so this grieving wife
said her husband's soul came to her when
the calf
licked her neck and hair and kissed her
and followed her upstairs which was
enough to convince her it was her
husband's name was kut reborn it's a
it's a calf well he's born
wait her husband's name is could reborn
no reborn is just the the word
you know it's like her husband was
reborn reincarnation
it's just and then the word reborn
follows the sentence
i was like we have to explain
reincarnation to a group of asian people
we're really going off the deep end
i don't understand
we're drinking too many red bulls
[Laughter]
so she had said that i believe we grew
up christian is my husband because
whatever he does
is in exactly the same way as my husband
did when he was alive
i believe the calf is my husband because
whatever he does is in the exact same
way whatever makes you horny [ __ ]
i don't care
that's the law of the land man if my
grandma was alive today she goes
man that [ __ ] monkey oh that reminds
me of your grandpa and i'm all like
that's dope
that's your vibrator now cool
dude monkeys are very human-like that's
true maybe a lizard or something
different
if you ever see you go to a zoo and
watch like a gorilla you're like holy
[ __ ] yeah that's me right there that's
just a person yeah that's seriously just
a person very dude chimpanzee the way
they interact with each other and they
look at you you can just be like that
[ __ ] is the person they're
thinking the exact same thing i don't
think i'm that different from that thing
right there you're not that different
from that thing over there like size
wise pretty you're pretty close pretty
close like a silver back
he's like a small who who would win a
child a child silverback or bart in a
wrestling match
dude dude this guy has an ass of a
gorilla too he got a big old fat ass
he kind of walks like a gorilla and [ __ ]
dude have you guys seen uh
chimps there's these two brother chimps
that have the same disease where they
they got like mange yeah yeah they
[ __ ] look ripped like bruce lee dude
and that's all from bananas and grass
that's what they're saying
dude so you could be a vegetarian be
jacked right
bananas and grass
i don't know bananas and grass can make
somebody so real how many bananas will
you have to eat to get one pound one
gram of protein per pound following your
rules man how many bananas do i gotta
eat something else dude i'm gonna have
40 000 calories of
how many bananas
how many proteins has been bananas
there's a lot of carbs bro what else
there's like one gram maybe probably not
even a gram they're vegetarian as [ __ ]
right 1.3 grams and one medium banana
this bar right here
look at his balls whoa he got some big
old balls
i just want to hold him in my hand just
that guy dude this this silverback has
been training with dk he's been
practicing his his one-inch punch
dude
that's the monkey that's the chip with
the disease
you say dk i think of donkey donkey kong
that's the chip with the disease that
that has the hair problem you call it a
disease
it looks like he's doing the asian squat
where you smoke outside the [ __ ]
sound dude
look at his doubts man hell yeah do you
think he knows he's jack uh no
do you think he has like self-image
issues like he has body dysmorphia
yeah he's like i'm not bluffing doesn't
matter don't those guys get a twig and
go to a [ __ ] ant hill and just lick
ants all day and that's how they're
getting buffed dude just eating hella
[ __ ] handsome next level though
bro this is like me on a warm warm day
you know what i mean you got long balls
anthony only on warm days you know
batman balls he got working man wrists
dude
might never look like that yeah that's
the one by the railroad tracks yeah he's
just chilling
off for like three years
like that not even with the magnifying
glass apple works like bapu looks like
he works on a coal mine
he looks like a black lung can he do
with the ball that big only one you
remember i mean i was a kid that's been
on like 15 years ago when they had like
humans fight animals
in competitions like sport competitions
put them in the ring yeah not like
physically fight they'd be like who
could hang longer an olympic gymnast or
a chimpanzee oh really or no they had it
with like an orangutan or something and
then they had i think they had kobayashi
eat hot dogs against a bear
i do remember this i do remember that
and then they had like a man race a
cheetah but the man got like a 30 second
head start
or like a cheetah had to like race a
ferrari or something crazy yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] cool what shows this
called yeah just like one of those like
specials i was like on abc i like those
damn yeah i don't know i've never seen
that i think i think another dude ate
like bowls of mayonnaise against
like an anteater it was something weird
i remember i was like first of all i was
like an animal is not going to eat
mayonnaise okay like why don't you put
ants in front of the ant eater yeah what
the [ __ ] is who won the hanging contest
the gymnast but i remember because the
orangutan he's got born right yeah he
just got bored it got bored it clearly
it was like hanging by one arm at one
point and like doing [ __ ] like this
it was like it's like and then the
gymnast was like
like you're doing [ __ ] like that and the
rank takes like one finger that was even
known
to like stick it in his ear and like
didn't even know man
he doesn't know what he's doing like the
human is fighting for like
all of the human race
just pride
and the monkey is just like yeah
whatever i'm a [ __ ] circus animal
this [ __ ] sucks like you know what i
mean like
like it just sucks he's like give me the
[ __ ] out of here monkeys are so much
stronger than human beings emotionally i
don't know how we survived man like
we're just so weak it's the brain
yeah yeah our brains are bigger i think
my biology teacher in in uh college
he he works with with monkeys a lot and
he works with this chimpanzee that's
super friendly but uh one day he let the
monkey out of the cage and the cage is
two thousand pounds and he saw the
monkey just like lifted off the ground
like two inches like
like he was playing with this just
deadlift the cage
grab my face i'm just dead yeah and
don't they do that like don't they go
for the face you just take it off yeah i
think that's how they fight yeah because
they're human so they know they're like
they're just like they're like
it's like oh they don't know how to do
this though
the only way to stop a [ __ ] monkey
from ripping off your face they just
backhand you i mean we saw that dude's
knuckles yeah dude that's a big [ __ ]
talk about his boss still or that too he
could probably if he tea bagged you
you'd cause a concussion just drop it on
your head yeah that's a that's straight
up cte after getting tea bagged by the
monkeys those looked heavy how many
kilograms that's like a [ __ ]
kettlebell
dropping it from ten feet just on your
head this ball stack is 800 bananas i
look for sure it's like honda you know
when he honda jumps and he like lifts
his leg i was watching
it's like that it's pretty much the same
as monkeys balls
do you think humans are supposed to be
like stronger like chimps but because of
our lifestyle we're like fragile as [ __ ]
no because like imagine if we were born
in the wild we lived there we hung
around on trees we were [ __ ] like
that all day so they say that hunters
and gatherers were as athletic as like
olympic
athletes yeah because you had to they
didn't look like that on the oregon
trail yeah you were dead and you had to
be we're supposed to have an extra layer
of skin too like a thicker layer or like
calloused up stuff oh and then we
invented clothes
irrigation we could have been so much
tougher but we had to [ __ ] start
wearing clothes and shoes why would we
do that there was like putting room it's
not just tough fires like the kids in
like the early 19th century are way
smarter than kids today really are they
no way imagine like learning vocab and
math when you're in like the early 1900s
like people were [ __ ] like
shakespearean poets the way they were
like speaking in the in the etiquette
that they had to endure the true if you
read like the gettysburg address
yeah it's
it's like a high level but it's all in
cursive though who can read it which is
also high level who wants a recursive
you know if you knew you had less time
if you knew you were gonna die at 30 you
would get smarter they had better work
ethics
but there's no hashtags in the game if i
was going to get scarlett fever you know
yeah that's true dysentery wipe you out
yeah yeah dog like you get diarrhea and
it's okay i go and i go get thai food
i'm like thai spicy i got diarrhea next
day that would kill me 100 years ago i
would get
that's true
and they didn't have many things to jack
off to see that's that's one thing that
loses a lot of guys loses so much time
they didn't have things to jack off to
but at the same time if you saw like
ankle skin you'd be [ __ ] hard so i
mean that's the spank bang that's their
spank bank huh yeah ankles
old-timey ankle skin martha forgot to
wear her socks today oh martha ladies
they like take off their huge dress and
they have like underwear that covers
their whole body still in white you're
like oh my god
form-fitting dude
that's why now you know why indian
aunties are always showing their
mid-drifts bro
it's getting a little spicy out there
spicy food spicy women baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you